tél
bonjour et merci de nous rejoindre sur
public sénat et sur rfo nous sommes à la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de la
réunion pour suivre la table ronde qui
clôture la visite de la mission
d'information sur la situation des dom
présidé par serge larcher et dont le
rapporteur est eric doligé alors pendant
trois jours cette délégation sénatoriale
a pu s'entretenir avec les acteurs
politiques économiques et sociaux de
l'île
des visites de terrain était également
au programme autour de sujets comme la
jeunesse l'environnement l'insertion
régionale les politiques publiques et
les finances des collectivités locales
pour situer la réunion quelques chiffres
plus de 750 mille habitants une
population très jeune 40 % des
réunionnais au moins de 20 ans et un
taux de chômage qui tourne autour de 25%
le plus important des dom
c'est dire l'importance de
l'intervention publique est d'ailleurs
il va en être largement question lors de
cette table ronde qui réunit qui réunit
donc les membres de la délégation et les
élus réunionnais hasard du calendrier
elle se tient le jour même de
l'ouverture à la réunion des états
généraux pour l'outre-mer
les deux démarches sont complémentaires
et je pense que sur ce point monsieur le
président vous me contredirait pas je
vous passe la parole
je remercie les plus importants pour
nous deux qui sont déplacés ici à la
réunion de rencontre et comme vous
l'avez souligné
et avec les représentants du monde du
travail l'économie de la culture des
responsables politiques et nous avons
estimé important utile de rencontrer les
maires houle pour parler avec eux des
problèmes très importante qui concerne
les finances locales
vous savez que
d'appuyer d'après ce que nous avons su
de par nos rencontres
nombre de communes de la réunion on
décompte des situations dans une
situation budgétaire très difficile et
la dette infinie sme et par conséquent
nous savons aussi qu'il ya c'est un
nombre d'écritures certain nombre de
difficultés qui s'annoncent à l'horizon
par conséquent de façon à pouvoir
dégager des perspectives de façon à
pouvoir maintenir un certain niveau
d'investissement et pourtant pour
l'activité donc l'emploi pour une ville
qui connaît un chômage important et pour
surtout une jeunesse qui tiennent qui
frappés par cette gangrène et un niveau
très important
par conséquent nous sont venues entre
primaire leur parler de nos problèmes de
leurs recettes qui sont la plupart
l'octroi de mer qui opposait les deux ce
qui représentait une qui est très
important pour le religieuse et près de
40% la voie libre cette nuit venant des
quatre taxes
le produit des quatre taxes c'est à dire
la faune au foncier bâti le foncier non
bâti la taxe d'habitation et dans une
moindre mesure la taxe professionnelle
et puis voir avec eux aussi le problème
de la dotation globale de fonctionnement
se tenir
ce concert l'état aux communes
alors si vous voulez bien 79 07
importants sur lesquels les buts des
communes peuvent s'asseoir c'est ce qui
garantit même le malheur fait qu' il y à
des hypothèques sur la principale sur
l'une des principales au cercle
je parlais de la primaire et si vous
sent que je voudrais que les guerres d
un petit peu leur problème
les cisailles six ont envisagé des
solutions interactives quand on sait que
notre mère qui est une taxe qui était
situé depuis très longtemps depuis le
17e siècle donc à l'époque de la
colonisation ou financer les communes
aujourd'hui
elle et elle ne peut être mise en place
a perduré que jusqu'en 2000 en 2014
c'est à dire demain de maintenant on a
beaucoup d'idées mer on a dit mais je ne
peux pas reprendre les propos qui sont
très déplacé nous n'avons pas joué non
plus les mauvais rôles ici mais ce qu'il
faut s'avancer que les maires tous les
jours s'emploie à développer leur
commune et à proposer à nos populations
des solutions et qu'en faisant cela ils
ont joué le rôle de buvards sociale
c'est à dire qu'ils ont dû embaucher
distribuer des revenus disque lui et des
ressources à des familles qui étaient
démunis qui tourne à la situation
pauvreté et et et voilà c'est en faisant
cela ils ont plombé aussi obliger le
pouvoir dans quelle mesure l'état peut
considérer que les communes
il revient jouer le rôle de l'état si
aujourd'hui l'état ne peut pas de ce
côté férule une certaine solidarité en
voyant le problème de la dette le niveau
de la dotation globale de fonctionnement
voilà c'est les questions peut que je
sous lesquelles nous souhaiterions
intervenir
je ne veux pas que je ne souhaiterais
pas que nous passions passion de temps à
des années d'isolement trop technique
puisque nous avons une population qu'ils
observent ce nouveau grade qui coûtera
télévision et qui certainement ne
voudrais pas comprendre dans les zones
engagé au mythique est compréhensible
il faut d'autres démarche didactique de
façon à ce que tout le monde comprenne
pas les marchés mais cela je crois que
dès lors on comprend
eh bien on a des airs de pas forcément
de manière partisane ne comprend la
chose publique et on défend l'intérêt de
la commune les dires de chacun
alors si vous voulez juillet je veux
passer la parole à monsieur monsieur à
porter les ambitions qui monsieur eric
doligé mon ami exigé et pour compléter
éventuellement et lancer le débat
écoutez je remercie mon ami le président
de passer la parole simplement deux ou
trois remarques à bord on a eu beaucoup
d'auditions une bonne vingtaine en trois
jours on a senti beaucoup d'optimisme du
souci aussi bien sûr pour l'avenir mais
on
rencontrer des partenaires qui ont
énormément de projets que ce soit au
niveau des communes et au niveau des
entreprises et de tout ce qu'on a eu le
plaisir de voir
alors c'est vrai qu'il y a des soucis en
matière de financement des collectivités
et là nous sommes en phase de mer pour
un certain nombre qui nous ont présenté
leur projet ou qu'on est allé voir sur
le terrain on a rencontré madame
nationale lynda cloutier présidente du
département mais aussi monsieur paul
vergès président de la région et ils
nous ont brossé un peu leur situation
alors pour les mères il est vrai que
nous vu de la métropole pour un certain
nombre d'entre nous n'avons pas tout à
fait les mêmes problématiques que nous
n'avons pas le crois de mer nous n'avons
pas la même composition budgétaire de
celle qui est la vôtre ou souvent le
poids de mer pour présenter le 25 à 65 %
de la recette et on sait qu'il va y
avoir un certain ralentissement dont
peut-être moins de rentrées des
perspectives à terme qui peuvent être un
peu difficile donc c'est ça nous
interroge pour savoir quelles sont les
pistes que l'on doit suivre et notre
objectif c'est pouvoir à la suite des
échanges qu'on a eue avec l'ensemble de
nos interlocuteurs
mais en l'occurrence les élus faire des
propositions et pour faire des
propositions il faut que l'on ait un
certain nombre de remarques et de
propositions de la part de nos
interlocuteurs donc ils vont peut-être
nous faire part de leur situation
vous avez effectivement présents trois
maires ou leurs représentants
monsieur jean yves langenier pour le
présenter et maire du port grosses
communes de la réunion avec son activité
portuaire importante
monsieur guinée représente la mairie de
saint-leu communes de l'ouest
helmand et puis monique orphé pour la
mairie de saint-denis donc je pense
chacun avec des problématiques précises
monsieur langenier vous l'été prendre la
parole le premier je veux bien ce qu'il
en soit le poignet mettons la ville du
pense effectivement une ville paradoxal
c'est une ville qui est des potières
c'est le seul port de commerce de la
réunion donc avec des zones activité
relativement importante et on a soit
l'habitude d'appeler la commune du port
le poumon économique de la réunion
et paradoxalement on a des taux de
chômage parmi les plus importants de la
réunion donc ça veut dire on est dans
une situation paradoxale ya de
l'activité mais en même temps il ya un
taux de chômage qui est catastrophique
et qui nous pose énormément de problèmes
et sur ce plan là le ce qui est toujours
liée au chômage c'est là le sur le plan
du logement
la difficulté d'avoir un logement on a
deux mille demandes de logements en
attente aujourd'hui pour une population
qui fait quarante mille habitants et est
donc ces deux problèmes l'emploi et le
logement ça représente des grosses
difficultés auxquelles on a fait face et
les finances communales ne suffisent pas
pour faire face disons aux besoins pour
rattraper le retard puisque la réunion
est un département de pilleurs 60 ans
depuis 1946 et on a des retard
d'équipement la ville du port ne fait
pas exception à cela et on a une
démographie qui est relativement
dynamique avec donc chaque année des
besoins nouveaux
les retards de plus les besoins ça fait
qu' on est confronté toujours à la des
difficultés ou qu'on est toujours dans
la course contre la montre pour essayer
de
de faire face à nos obligations et les
financements nous ne nous permettent pas
les finances communales nous permettent
pas d'avoir une politique qui réponde de
façon satisfaisante aux besoins de notre
population et les inquiétudes de forte
qu'on a tant pour la taxe
professionnelle puisque étant donné que
notre commune a la chance d'avoir des
zones d'activités ça représente une taxe
professionnelle qui même si aujourd'hui
n'est plus directement au bénéfice de la
commune puisque on est membre d'une
communauté d'agglomération
interprofessionnel a été donc mutualisée
au haut niveau de la communauté
d'agglomération ne bénéficie plus
directement de la taxe professionnelle
mais c'est une recette
le tireur relativement importante malgré
tout pour notre commune et l'octroi de
mer les inquiétudes qu'on a aujourd'hui
sur l'octroi de mer bien évidemment me
le strat mère est une part importante
des recettes communales c'est donc ces
deux éléments taxe professionnelle et
octroi de mer qui constitue aujourd'hui
nos préoccupations les plus les plus
fortes
comment peut-on imaginer l'avenir sont
des solutions alternatives et là sur ce
plan là on a du mal à imaginer qu'ils ne
puissent pas y avoir de solution
alternative en cas de disparition de
l'une ou de l'autre de ces taxes du port
ce qu'il faut savoir pour vous ce soir
j'ai pu visiter la réunion continue son
pressing depuis trois jours seul à le
penser l'une des communes c'est le
poumon économique qui ta peau mate ont
expliqué qu'elles ne trouvent le plus
d'activités et monsieur le maire nous
dit toutes ces activités de communic
pointe et bien que je suis entre la
commune de retard d'équipement et ma
commune à des besoins nouveaux du fait
de la croissance démographique était
très important autrement dit que faire à
la question est que faire alors si vous
regarder d'observer la structure même de
budget voulu le budget communal
et la structure des recettes de faire
face à des dépenses qui sont importantes
nous sommes mais ils sont d'autant plus
importante que ce qu'on en oublie
souvent c'est que nous sommes un jeune
prometteur contre hôpital ce qui suppose
que nous avons usure des matériaux qui
ce qui est beaucoup plus importante que
nous sommes loin de la métropole et que
tout ce qui est notre principal
fournisseur de tout ce que nous avons
des avis trop pâle donc l'éloignement
des frais de nouveaux plus important qui
fait des coûts de construction ou de
réhabilitation qui sont fort important
alors et c'est ça la vie quotidienne du
maire et comment faire pour boucler le
tout pouvoir apporter tous des réponses
concrètes et précises aux besoins et aux
aspirations de la population mais en
même temps et dans le même temps et
financé alors vous parlez de poids de
mer s'ils voulaient nous allons revenir
mais prenons d'abord si vous voulez par
la méthode la recette celle que c'est à
l'état
la dgf la dotation de fonctionnement qui
étaient importantes qui est certainement
à 10,07 de budget nous le collègue
virapoullé sénateur virapoullé avait il
ya deux ans trois ans je crois avait
avec nous avions proposé un abattement
visant à prendre en compte toutes les
tous les handicaps en fait un amendement
de l'ultrapériphérie cité c'est à dire
quoi c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas tout ce
que nous avions venir et c'est à dire
les défis les écouler sur coup les yeux
de matériaux etc et les grands tours
contre vos que nous servons à nos agents
qui s'y fait que les communaux qui sont
allés les budgets sans doute à d'autres
relevés et c'est c'était un amendement
qui cherchait visait à abonder pour les
communes et la marine la dotation
globale de fonctionnement
on n'attendait pas des milliards qu'on
attendait quand même quelque chose
d'assez consistant froid on compte
besoin le cedar et produits présents le
sénat a adopté adopté je passe le
contrôle devient poulet le sénat a
adopté mais malheureusement en deuxième
lecture
c'était donc une occasion
le budget des partenaires voire 2000
2006 2007
mais nous ce cet amendement a été rejeté
par l'assemblée nationale
je vais pas viser monsieur victor y est
annoncée du pal alors l'objet du tout
mais vous savez que pour faire pour
faire rentrer chez nous on dit souvent
tout faire pour faire entrer un clou
dans une planche il faut taper retaper
étape exemple c est apprendre de tapei
fidèles à part rentrée même si le bois
dur même s'ils n'ont pas de la guyane au
lieu de guyane eh bien eh bien je crois
que c'est occulter ce qu'il faut il faut
il faut il faut il faut persévérer
alors nous l'avons fait on n'a pas
réussi mais il faut revenir il faut
toujours revenir et c'est tous ensemble
que les départements d'outre-mer nous
parlons du monde voit et nous avons une
démarche commune les temps attendre
parce que nous nous appuyons la sueur
aux fondements qui est important qu'il y
correspond à une réalité sait pas on
n'invente rien c'est mérité besoin et
qui équipe lui qui est billets ambulante
et ouais c'est cet aspect que je voulais
fait ressortir une notation globale de
fonctionnement qui a été tout récemment
remodelée trois ans de cela qui a pris
en compte des paramètres nouveau
monsieur génériques
mais qui dit petit avantage mais qui
apporte quelques réponses positives
grande commune connaît surtout en guyane
mais qu'ils y puisent l'eau ne rapporte
aucune solution satisfaisante
voilà alors là de la dgf c'est un
problème ce tacle sur lequel nous devons
quand même et il faut que tout le
commerce cela alors mon cher ami vitoria
tous voulaient répondre qu'on n'a pas
cherché à traiter à peu les attaquants
messi c'est le président de la mission
et permettez moi au nom de mes
compatriotes réunionnais salué la
présence ici de nos collègues ultra
marins mais aussi des collègues
nationaux
je pense que l'outre-mer d'une façon
générale a besoin aujourd'hui d'un
nouveau regard et les parlementaires
nationaux ont un jour un rôle important
à jouer dans la connaissance d'abord de
nos différents territoires de nos
problèmes mais aussi en étant des agents
aussi politique de communication pour
convaincre des fois les plus
récalcitrants sur le bien-fondé de telle
ou telle mesure et j'ai en tête cet
amendement qui a été évoqué tout à
l'heure qui me paraît être un bon
amendement c'éatit n'est peut-être pas
passé parce que en son temps peut-être
aussi il n'y avait pas
cette modernisation de la méthode
parlementaire la coproduction
législative les changes entre les les
des deux assemblées et c'est une
démarche aujourd'hui qui est innovante
qu'il faut certainement mettre en oeuvre
la discussion de la lodeom a permis
justement de mieux nous connaître entre
sénateurs et députés et j'espère que
nous allons continuer à travailler dans
ce sens le président vient d'évoquer le
problème des financements des
collectivités et notre ami le maire du
port cité maritime avec tout
tous les problèmes qu'on connaît liée à
une ville portuaire
malgré un taux de croissance avec un
potentiel fiscal important se rend
compte
face aux urgences face aux problèmes de
la jeunesse dépassement de la jeunesse
des personnes âgées
mais d'une façon générale de la
population il faut des moyens
supplémentaires et pour obtenir ces
moyens supplémentaires
il est certes nécessaire d'avoir une
politique d'aménagement qui va
développer d'autres types de ressources
mais il est important d'avoir surtout
l'aide de l'état qui qui est le garant
de la mécanique à à mettre en oeuvre
aussi bien sur le plan des dotations on
l'a vu tout à l'heure mais c'est aussi
des mécaniques jean défiscalisation
qui pourrait être allé encore plus loin
je pense aux stations d'épuration des
traitements des eaux je pense grand parc
public qui font défaut dans les villes
et qui sont vraiment des équipements se
curant en tout cas j'avais milité avec
d'autres collègues pour que le fonds
d'investissement spécifique ou
exceptionnel qui a été créée par le des
hommes soit aussi consacrée à ce grand
projet ces grands travaux pour permettre
aux collectivités d'avoir des moyens
supplémentaires alors mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs ont démarré par la réunion
vous aurez l'occasion d'aller voir
également les autres départements
de trois maires moi j'ai fait l'inversé
j'ai rencontré quelques collègues que
ici dans leur département puisque j'ai
aussi une mission au niveau de la mise
en oeuvre du revenu de solidarité active
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on peut parler
d'une façon unanime c'est l'ensemble des
communes de l'outre-mer qui connaît des
difficultés
d'où l'urgence d'avoir un plan une
démarche cohérente commune doit sortir
l'ensemble de nos collectivités de cette
situation financière dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons ensuite il nous avons de
plus en plus des communautés
d'agglomération qui sont aussi des
véritables outils d'aménagement de
développement économique et chacun
pourra se rendre compte sans
développement économique
pas de développement social et le social
tel que cela a été mis en oeuvre pendant
de nombreuses années aujourd'hui et doit
être revu et corrigé et j'ai envie de
dire à nos collègues qui qui qui ce
qu'ils ont vécu qui ont visité la
réunion durant ces trois jours eh bien
nous sommes là un peuple debout qui a
envie d'aller encore plus loin des
données la formation la plus
qualifiantes possible mais nous voulons
aussi que nos jeunes formés puisse
trouver du travail ici
nous voulons aussi utiliser notre
éloignement qui est un handicap mais
comme aussi un atout de coopération dans
la région avec les états voisins et
surtout nous avons besoin de bien
comprendre notre projet de développement
de nous laisser travailler en toute
quiétude dans la confiance et cette
confiance doit être partagé et je salue
encore une fois le travail qui est fait
en ce moment à la fois par l'assemblée
sénatoriale et l'assemblée nationale
pour aller dans un même objectif servir
nos compatriotes ultramarins
tu t'es merci beaucoup à vous nous avez
emmené un petit peu loin de la dgf
peut-être sur laquelle on va revenir
mais merci vous avez aussi planté un
décor plus générale madame waro vouliez
intervenir sur cette dotation
comme le disait le président larcher
être tous unis pour dire effectivement
elle ne suffit pas aujourd'hui elle doit
être plus importante pour les communes
d'outre-mer de tête plus important pour
les communes d'outre-mer
alors on est très gentil autour de cette
table
on apprend par la lodeom bas on se
connaît senna député c est pourquoi pas
mais je crois que le fond on n'ose pas
bulle bien aborder le fond comme il se
doit
je pense que là il faut voir par le
biais de l'octroi de mer qui sera
supprimée en 2013 ou 2014 a en tout cas
atteindre en 2014 rapporte un an de plus
bon ok menace mais pour l'instant ça va
vers cela en tout cas aucune solution
alternative
le problème qui vont ce qui va se poser
pour nos petites communes on a nommé est
là le maire de du port et la poumon de
l'île commune très vivace on va dire
avec son port bon client qui a quand
même pas mal de recettes
mais les petites communes qui sont
totalement retirés et nous savons qu'ils
n'ont aucune zone industrielle qui na na
pas une entreprise sur leur commune qui
ne vivent qu'avec l'octroi de mais on va
dire qui représente le budget entre 40
et 60% alors que vont devenir ces
petites communes quand on connaît tous
ce que les communes ont de compétences
et au fur et à mesure on connaît l'état
se désengage et on va tout sur le dos
des communes quand on voit par exemple
les communes qui ont à faire face à la
démographie bien évidemment à construire
les écoles maternelles primaires à doter
ces écoles du mobilier des effets
scolaires à nour et à ses enfants
je ne vois vraiment pas comment ces
communes vont faire quand on voit les
grandes communes ne pourront pas s'en
sortir et et puis je me dis nom du dieu
il faut quand même arrêter de dire tout
gentiment ça se passe bien nous cette
mission a été demandée parce qu'il ya eu
la crise a fait des années que elle
était attendue quand même c'est
l'aboutissement j'ai envie de dire des
années et des années d'une politique qui
n'était pas adapté pour le développement
de notre pays qui n'ont pas permis qui
n'a pas donné les outils les moyens à la
réunion de se développer a justement on
va arriver sur ses atouts mais je ne
veux pas trop débordés puisqu'on aura le
temps que les atouts de la réunion
produisent une richesse marchande etc
dans la richesse ma chambre
qu'on crée de l'emploi c'est ça le vrai
problème je crois qu'il faudrait aborder
et peut-être je m'emporte un peu je ne
sais pas mais on est vraiment tous
gentils nous aurons nous aurons bientôt
2000 assistants d'éducation qui seront
sur le le bord du chemin
jeté à la rue nous avons là dans les
journaux le 4000 je crois le
licenciement c'est que la situation va
mal et l'état nous ne voyons pas notre
état français nous défendre à bruxelles
c'est vrai nous avons nos députés
européens mais non de dieu nous sommes
aussi dans l'état français et que fait à
ce moment là l'état français par les
ventes dans les joints sur la ds et la
dgf aussi tu comprends vêtements gélita
hausse est de recentrer le débat est
très bien la réunion n'a vu 2 par
rencontre à sète l'homme d'acteurs
économiques et de représentants du monde
du travail il doit il n'a assemblé que
il ya eu de gros travaux publics de
l'autre a bossé fort biais d'un
excellent c'était magnifique des faits
je pense que c'est pour le plus grand
bien à vocation d'ouvrir l'aise mais on
arrive à une rupture entre chantante de
chantier ce qui peut permettre au btp
qui est de locomotive de développement
pour la croissance économique et c'est
ce soit il faut trouver des marchés qui
donne les maristes la commande publique
si le département c'est la région et les
communes nous savons a décidé mais
aujourd'hui la réponse de savoir qu'on
fait si les mêmes les maires seront où
les communes seront en mesure
de relayer ensemble relayée par des
grands concerts les gros travaux mais
pas maintenant sept ans de travaux alors
la question se pose comment pourra-t-il
de faire si ils ont décidé s'ils sont
dans des situations de budgétaire très
contraint
alors et c'est très présent mais je
l'état nous arrivons à plutôt mer à ces
problèmes là le généraux c'est que cette
raison que nous avons décortiqué dans un
premier temps les recettes des communes
voir les problèmes les répertorier les
voir dans quelle mesure nous nous
parlementaires c'est notre dessinateur
dans quelle mesure nous pourrons porter
ces revendications les faire avancer
et la première chose je dis concernant
la dgr il faut mutualiser tout
l'outre-mer ce mutualiser les efforts
vous permettre d'arriver à un résultat
quel résultat c'est que l'on prenne une
situation qui est réel que nous vivons
tous les jours c'est l'ultra perry cité
des départements l'europe reconnaît que
nous avons des handicaps structurels
comment la nation française dont nous
faisons partie ne peut-elle pas
confondre ces handicaps là c'est pas
l'heure du vocabulaire s'est
concrètement les chiffres et les autres
nous ont manié a dit à petit nous
d'abord sur le front de mer
nos armes ou sur le niger mais nous
allons bientôt sur le produit et sur les
autres concepts mais il n'y a aucun
doute là dessus
donc je voulais poursuivre toujours mais
je pense avoir tout de suite à celui
passé avec la me demandez pas pourquoi
chez toi patients alors si on passe le
micro et peut-être un petit peu loin de
vous alors voilà le temps qu on le passe
devant banc
oui il y a constat quand même autour de
la table il ya un réel problème au
niveau des finances locales de toutes
les collectivités d'outre-mer ça tout le
monde l'a constaté à partir de ce
constat maintenant il faut venir aux
solutions bon celle qui est la plus
menacée parmi les recettes c'est
l'octroi de mer à la mémoire ou à raison
chez nous aussi des communes qui vivent
à 90% de l'octroi de mer les petites
communes
les grosses en des ressources fiscales
l'octroi de mer représente 25 à 30 % de
la recette
mais pour les petites communes c'est 90%
toi même tu l'as dit l'octroi de mer
existe depuis très longtemps donc la la
la détruire houle
on l'a supprimée pardon rapidement ce
serait conduire encore une plus grande
faillite des collectivités locales même
s'ils sont pas mises en faillite
donc il faut qu'elle reste ou bien il
faut qu'il est qu'il ya une recette de
substitution
je rappelle quand même que l'autonomie
financière des collectivités locales
c'est un principe constitutionnel et
l'état est garant de la mise à
disposition des collectivités des
ressources pour assurer leurs missions
de service public ça là aussi je pense
qu'il faut pas le cacher nous étions à
bruxelles n'y a pas très longtemps et à
bruxelles on nous a dit qu'il y avait un
rapport d'étape qui devait être remis
par l'état français pour pouvoir faire
en sorte que le bras de mer soient
reconduits et jusqu'à maintenant ce
rapport n'a pas été transmis par l'état
français est tout à fait que tout à fait
d'accord donc c'est une première
démarche que nous pourrions avoir
on en a parlé dernièrement à bruxelles
mais ça aussi il faut qu'on incite
l'état français à faire déjà ce premier
travail
il faut rappeler quand même que l'octroi
de mer vont a été mis en place dans un
souci de développement économique il
s'agissait de
de protéger notre production locale nous
sommes en europe ces deux marchés
communs l'europe ça fait très longtemps
fait en sorte que cette taxe soit
supprimé bon ça c'est un problème
européen mais nous restons dans le iv
franco-français 607 recettes
nous ne pouvons pas vivre donc il faut
première solution première démarche en
sorte qu'elle soit pérenne et jusqu'à
maintenant jusqu'à preuve du contraire
les menaces et mâcha qu fois elle est
maintenue parce que l'état français n'a
pas trouvé autre chose mais arrive quand
même à convaincre ses autres partenaires
de la nécessité pour ces territoires du
maintien de cette taxe donc je crois que
moi personnellement comme l'octroi de
mer on trouvera quelque chose au niveau
de la dgf effectivement dans la loi
girardin
on avait parlé de la mise en place d'une
dotation spécifique pour l'outre-mer
dotation d'ultra périphéricité et là
aussi l'état n'a pas suivi arguant du
fait que bon les handicaps
effectivement il fallait pas en tenir
compte on nous laisse toujours toujours
dans la même enveloppe qui ne progresse
pas ça aussi je pense qu'il ya un gros
travail pour caen fasse rentrer dans la
dgf un certain nombre de critères qui ne
sont pas pris en compte
à l'époque en tenant compte de
l'éloignement par rapport à la métropole
du potentiel fiscal du nombre d'enfants
bon tous ces critères ont disparu et le
principal critère qui est retenu seuls
critères nombre d'habitants bon ça peut
aller dans le sens de certaines grandes
communes
mais pour les petites communes aussi la
dgf c'est la portion congrue
il ya bien des grosses communes il ya
beaucoup de petites communes est sûre
c'est là aussi je pense qu'un gros
travail à faire bon il ya d'autres
critères
d'autres recettes qui permettait à
l'époque aux petites communes aussi
parce que moi je n'avais moko petite
commune et je suis maire d'une petite
commune
dix mille habitants c'est une cause
commune en france mais c'est quand même
une petite commune dans l'outre-mer nous
avions le fr dès le fonds régional de
développement économique est une partie
de l'octroi de mer qui était répartie
puis un litre la dune a trop vite il
faut faire un centre tout le monde
comprenne non
eq rapide et fender il faut d'expliquer
ce que ce fonds j'ai bien dit ça le
fonds régional développement économique
est une part de l'octroi de mer qui
logiquement est réservée aux
investissements
à l'époque ça aussi c'était répartis par
la région en fonction des
investissements des petites communes
alors que maintenant bon c'est réparti
en fonction du nombre d'habitants et ses
des grosses communes qui en bénéficient
au détriment des petites communes donc
voilà pour moi elle quelques points
précis sur laquelle on peut déjà discuté
sam yeh elle n'aurait pas y est
d'intervenir
moi je voudrais dire que je me réjouis
de cette mission qui a été décidé par le
président du sénat d'autant plus que le
président de notre commission des
affaires sociales avait émis l'idée il
ya deux ans d'une grande mission dans
tout l'outre-mer pour examiner l'ampleur
de tous les problèmes sociaux
est-ce qu'il entendait régulièrement
tous les parlementaires évoqué ses
problèmes dans l'hémicycle ou même en
commission alors je nous avons constaté
que nos collègues
au fil des auditions semblé tempérer
leur opinion sur scène un dossier qui
était délicat comme celui de l'octroi de
mer qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure et
les professionnels ont asséné des
chiffres ils ont des cantiques et le
mécanisme de certains dispositifs qui
avait auparavant la possibilité de
déclencher des grimaces ou des
grincements de dents donc c'était
vraiment un réel plaisir de voir leurs
réticences s'évanouir et leurs intérêts
croître pour notre département
alors ils ont bien enregistré que dans
beaucoup de domaines la réunion est une
terre de paradoxes une terre de
contrastes
par exemple nous avons de nombreuses
créations d'entreprises
nous avons un taux de croissance de 5%
depuis une dizaine d'années mais malgré
cela nous avons encore un taux de
chômage qui est très important nous
avons de nombreuses créations
d'entreprises tous les ans nous avons à
aussi mais la durée de vie de ces
entreprises et cote à cause du manque de
formation notamment dans le domaine de
la gestion
nous avons aussi des problèmes des
lectrices qui sont importants mais à
côté cela nous avons parfois des élèves
qui obtiennent 20 de moyenne au
baccalauréat
donc je pense qu'il faut signaler les
aspects un peu négatif mais aussi les
aspects positifs de ce qui existe chez
nous bon l'alcoolisme par exemple fait
beaucoup de dégâts et nous avons le taux
d'abstinence
je veux bien je bien sûr je ne veux pas
être censuré ces passionnés pas l'objet
de bonnes intentions
seulement nous sommes dans les
ressources des communes et après nous
allons dans un deuxième temps de revenir
sur ces problèmes la mission des
galeries pour ce que nous sommes venus
trouver des solutions aux problèmes qui
existent
on va les d'aborder dans un deuxième
temps je sais mais excusez moi mais je
suis prise par le temps et je dois
absolument extreme et voilà alors
l'alcoolisme fait beaucoup de dégâts
mais nous avons quand même le taux
d'atteinte ou d un taux d'accidents qui
est beaucoup plus important que la
moyenne nationale
donc c'est pour vous montrer tous les
paradoxes tous les contrastes qui a dans
notre île alors nos entreprises ont
besoin de cadres mais souvent elles vont
recruter en métropole malgré le nombre
de surdiplômés qui augmente d'année en
année
bien alors nous avons aussi de
nombreuses propositions
un des professionnels des
socioprofessionnels et le but de notre
mission est de les analyser d'essayer de
les concrétiser
pour enrayer tous les freins au
développement voilà je vous remercie
j'aurais juste
quand même pas en fasse peur à nozomi
d'outre-mer sur un certain nombre de
sujets d'abord contrairement à ce qu'a
dit tout à l'heure j'ai et aarau il
n'est pas prévu de supprimer en 2014
l'octroi de mer il est prévu on est à mi
temps en 2004 il a été décidé qu'en 2014
il y aurait une revoyons qu'on reverrait
le problème de l'octroi de mer est qu'à
mi temps on a un rapport à rendre et
comme l'a dit georges patient il est pas
tout à fait bien vendu comme il le
faudrait donc il ya encore du travail à
faire mais l'octroi de mer il n'a pas
été décidé de le supprimer
c'est à nous de démontrer que c'est un
outil intéressant et de qualité et je
crois que c'est le rôle des
parlementaires de travailler sur le
sujet est une des raisons pour
lesquelles on est là je pense aussi
qu'on ne peut pas dire que l'état est
abandonné la réunion pour y être venu
plusieurs fois quand je regarde
l'évolution en 20 ans de la réunion se
renvoyaient il ya 20 ans est ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui à une évolution
considérable est extrêmement positive et
avec un taux de progression de 5% par an
on en rêve nous en métropole donc il
faut voir les aspects positifs bien sûr
il ya énormément de difficultés que l'on
connaît
mais il ne faut pas croire non plus que
les communes de la métropole ne
connaissent pas des difficultés
financement est par contre elle
on leur a dit comme ici d'ailleurs qu'
on va leur supprimer à la fin de l'année
la taxe professionnelle donc ça c'est
une certitude
alors que l'octroi de mer c'est pas une
certitude on fait simplement dire qu'il
ne faut pas c'est une inquiétude bon bah
on est là pour se battre tous les élus
et on est là pour gommer les inquiétudes
mais on est là pour répondre au souci
des mers et on est là pour essayer
d'apporter des outils en fonction de ce
qu'ils nous ont dit ou ce qu'ils vont
nous dire c'est ça qui est important
alors justement monique orphé première
adjointe du maire de saint denis la plus
grande commune en nombre d'habitants de
tout l'outre-mer avec les problèmes que
rencontrent vos collègues de nikki
la plus grande ville de l'autre mère 140
mille habitants et il ya un point sur
lequel je voudrais donc assister et
surtout relevé par rapport à cela dit le
sénateur larcher si l'europe nous a
placé un objectif 1 c'est parce que le
rock a considéré qu'on avait des
handicaps et l'europe nous aident de
façon considérable
et je suis d'accord avec le sénateur
larcher pour dire que je trouve dommage
que l'état français n'ait pas pris en
tout cas ces handicaps à la hauteur de
ce qu'elle est ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
et je veux m'expliquer parce que
aujourd'hui on considère un département
outre mer comme un département
métropolitain on est placé sur le même
pied d'égalité
or on a une situation économique et
sociale complètement différent monsieur
l'enjeu niel a dit tout à l'heure quand
on a une ville de 140 mille habitants et
je passe sur le plan aussi de façon
globale on a aujourd'hui 30 pouces 30 %
de chômage à la réunion
aucune ville aucun département de deux
métropoles na 30 % de chômage on a une
demande en logements qui est insuffisant
vingt-six mille demandes de logement
avait une situation quand même sociales
dramatiques
en clair 80% de la population peut-être
un peu moins salée je vais dire ce sont
10 % de la population vivent avec des
minima sociaux ou avec un salaire qui
avoisine tout juste le smic les gens
avec la crise ils sont frappés de plein
fouet et toutes les mesures prises par
le gouvernement que ce soit la
suppression des postes dans la fonction
publique nous frappent là aussi de plein
fouet
on parle de développement économique moi
je parlerais aujourd'hui d'un pari qu'on
a à relever des défis qu'on a à relever
en termes de développement humain et je
m'explique en développement humain est
ce que vous trouvez normal
qu'aujourd'hui un département comme la
réunion et un taux d'échec scolaire à
15% le double de la métropole vous êtes
à 7% aujourd'hui que un grand
département comme de l'outre-mer est
aujourd'hui un taux de réussite plutôt
un taux d'échec en france est de 53 % un
taux d'échec en mathématiques de 49%
est ce que vous trouvez ça normal
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui je pense
qu'on a encore un rattrapage à faire
c'est vrai qu'on a des atouts mais on a
encore des rattrapages à faire et il
faut nous aider à faire ce rattrapage on
parlait du bâti scolaire
effectivement aujourd'hui on a débattu
le bâti scolaire qui date de 30 ans la
région nous a aidés à un moment donné à
rénover s'est bâti scolaire mais c'est
une des conditions à la réussite
scolaire
une des conditions aussi c'est de créer
des postes en maternelle ce qui créa
aussi ce qui créera aussi de l'emploi
aujourd'hui nos enfants de 2 ans il ya
que 7% des enfants de 2 ans qui sont
scolarisés sont scolarisés alors qu'on
de métropole on est à 35 %
est ce que vous trouvez ça normal alors
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour nous aider
effectivement à relever notre niveau
d'éducation ce qui fait que demain on
aura de la main d'oeuvre pour et c'est
effectivement occupé des postes à la
réunion développement économique
oui on a on a
d'ailleurs un tissu économique dynamique
mais à condition aussi que derrière on
est des gens pour prendre ces postes et
pour développer également la réunion
donc aujourd'hui les communes doivent
faire face à toutes ces charges parce
que là aussi l'état ce sont des l'état
s'est désengagé a transféré à cette
énorme de compétences notamment en
termes de construction de logements sur
saint denis par exemple on n'est pas ce
qu'on va passer et c'est le 2e défi
qu'on va relever au niveau de saint
denis avec l'aide effectivement du
département de passer de 250 logements
par an à 500 logements par an et on l'a
inscrit dans le coffre
on veut bien faire cet effort mais à
condition derrière à nous aider aussi à
faire à cet énorme d'aménagement du
foncier parce que qui dit logements dits
aménagement du foncier avec tout le
problème d'assainissement qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui et ça ça a un coût c'est un
coup ça veut dire que là aussi faudrait
trouver des fonds pour aménager de
foncier vous en métropole vous l'avez
fait dans les années 50 où l'état vous a
aidé à aménager votre foncier à aménager
vous n'avez plus de problèmes
d'assainissement
aujourd'hui les maires alors je vous
entends qu il met les maires ont été mis
en examen
parce que il était hors norme sas est
spécifique à la réunion alors conteste
qu'enfin se dire oui on arrête de faire
du bla bla bla on pose vraiment les
problèmes on trouve des solutions
mais la solution c'est malheureusement
les finances c'est l'argent ce n'est pas
du bla bla bla écrire et puis nous dire
ça ira ça avance il ya du progrès il ya
du progrès mais on doit aujourd'hui
compte tenir compte tenu de la crise
allez un peu un peu plus vite
avoir des aides exceptionnelles pour
qu'on puisse faire avancer le projet et
je terminerai en disant il ya eu un plan
de relance on a eu un plan de relance on
nous a demandé nos mairies de faire
accélérer de fait des propositions de
faire accélérer projet on va nous
accorder effectivement un budget
supplémentaire au départ sur saint denis
en a sélectionné dix projets après on
nous a dit c'est un projet et au final
on a eu peu
ces deux projets si ce n'est rien donc
on n'a rien eu dans le plan de relance
donc c'est ça aussi il faut il faut le
dire parce que nous on veut bien
répondre à la commande publique
mais même en sortant des projets si
derrière on a pas de financement pour
faire accélérer ses projets là on ne
pourra pas répondre à la commande
publique
voilà c'est un nom de concerts que je
voulais faire je sais pas si la solution
est facile mais je pense que la balle
est dans le camp aussi de l'état qui
doit nous aider à sortir à faire face à
cette crise je ne parle pas je ne parle
pas de l'autre volet aussi qu'
aujourd'hui nous pose problème
on parle du secteur marchand mais on a
aussi on a besoin aussi d'un volet nos
marchands à travers des contrats et les
aider et vous savez qu'aujourd'hui quand
on prend un contrat aidé c'est là c'est
la mairie qui supporte des arrières
ensuite le coup de l'assedic
donc non seulement si on veut reprendre
un contrat aidé on prend le contrat aidé
et en payant plus l'assedic ça c'est une
réalité alors le préfet ici il nous a
aidé à écrire
il a écrit également à l'état pour dire
de prendre en charge ce volet assedic
pour que l'état les mairies des pas à
supporter ça mais c'est ce sont ces
problématiques que les députés que les
sénateurs doivent porter devant le
gouvernement pour qu'on ait des aides
supplémentaires pour qu'on nous aide à
sortir la tête de l'eau mais nous sommes
toutes les nuits sont là pour ça
justement je crois que toute la table
tout le monde reconnaît il faut pas de
fric et de bouleverser tout le monde
reconnaît qu'il ya des queues ya sept
ans de succès à la réunion on a vu des
beaucoup de succès il ya beaucoup
d'avancé mais il reste encore des
problèmes et d'où la mission elle voit
les monnaies succès elle dit bravo mais
surtout il reste des points de moins d
posco e&c ce qui n'intéresse pas si vous
voulez créer profit de la tat ici pour
que nous soyons vos avocats vos défauts
sur la bas il faut nous exposer le
problème est le financement des communes
est un problème alors je peux savoir
tout de suite à mon collègue je voulais
et pour finir et souhaite à faire le
poids de bunia parce que vélo savard
tiers la clé sens le poids de berre je
n'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est un impôt taxe qui est très ancien
qui épie servait à financer la finance
et les communes après la france et après
il ya eu il ya eu l'europe et la france
a vendu des guillemets l'autre mère
comme étant un dispositif susceptible de
favoriser le développement développer
des entreprises locales
la production locale et de ce fait la
voie locale
c'est ça aujourd'hui l'europe a demandé
il vous ça chacun 5
l'un des principes fondateurs de
l'europe c'est la libre circulation des
marchandises des intérêts des capitaux
l'europe a perçu la chose disponibles
comme les droits de douane ce qui était
compatible avec son président fondateur
par conséquent à interpeller les
gouvernements français qui après moult
débats en 2003 a obtenu une prolongation
c'est auprès de mer jusqu'à l'horizon
2014 soit pendant dix ans il était bien
entendu qu'en cours de route à mi
parcours le la france remettrait un
rapport aux autorités européennes pour
montrer la pertinence du dispositif en
regard de la création d'emplois
aujourd'hui sera pas nous at on dit à
bruxelles ne vous démontre c'est ce qu'a
dit les obliger donc il nous appartient
connaissance cela nous sénateurs de la
france de dire à la france écoutez
sérieux il faut battre les autres
clients place pour pouvoir montrer que
c'était est important que l'on
maintienne ce dispositif
parce que pour l'europe le financement
des communes parfois demers et eu un
problème franco français ça notre patte
dispositif vous il faut bien comprendre
cela bon alors à bout pour nous pour
nous leurs amarres et nous avons intérêt
que cela perdure et sera opéré
aujourd'hui si on ne met pas la bio
centre la balle au centre
s'il n'y a pas un rapport susceptibles
de prouver
il faudrait il faudrait que de ya deux
solutions soit le trouve une recette
alternative
auquel cas il faudra réfléchir dès
maintenant même si bruno dit parfois
oublié soit que la france obtienne la
mesure perdure mais ce sera une des
dispositions politiques et non pas par
une démonstration administratif vient
technique technique
voilà le problème alors nous allons nous
avons jusqu'à 2014
on en parle aujourd'hui parce qu'il ne
faut pas attendre jusqu'à 2014 pour le
moment par conséquent il faut le dire
nous sommes déjà adultes 1 il ya des
difficultés il faut certes il faut dire
la difficulté mais je passais pleurer il
faisait du bon il faut se battre
la vie est un combat et je choisis des
poulains politique il faut savoir ce
qu'on gagne tous les jours on doit mener
rien et à qui il faut se battre et ça ce
bateau aux comptes hier des espaces de
liberté mais d'actions si et des fatwas
merci président à ce stade de la
discussion
chacun s'accorde à féliciter la mission
moi j'aurais souhaité que un des axes
forts de cette mission consisterait à
arriver à la conclusion suivante c'est
que on reconnaît qu'il y ait un déficit
structurel des finances des
collectivités locales première
observation
deuxième observation le mot handicap a
été annoncée mois ce terme de me paie
pas trop je dis simplement nous avons
des réalités qui sont tout à fait
différents quelles sont ces réalités
qu'on ne retrouve pas ailleurs les
réalités en matière de phase de
développement
nous avons en sous-équipement déficit
infrastructurel que ce soit les chiffres
que j'ai pu observer hier du conseil
général de la réunion qui a rationné
beau par rapport à l'investissement qui
est supérieur par rapport à la moyenne
nationale
on pourrait dire les mêmes chiffres pour
la guyane est aussi la martinique et la
guadeloupe
ce qui veut dire que il y a à la fois la
nécessité de combler un déficit
infrastructurel dans des domaines qui
sont importants le lard
jean guadeloupe la réunion pardon nous
disaient qu'ils ont réalisé 40 lycées
par depuis un certain nombre d'années à
al harra en guyane c'est la construction
de deux lycées par part en guyane nous
avons des besoins et aimant également en
matière de construction haut niveau donc
des collèges et des écoles primaires est
de même de même nous devons être aussi à
la pointe à la pointe de la technologie
et nous avons rencontré ce matin donc
dans les salons de la préfecture
des spécialistes des entreprises qui se
positionne effectivement danser dans ces
secteurs qui sont innovants et qui sans
porter les créations d'emplois alors ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que par
rapport à ces réalités
admettons également reconnaissant le
également que la réponse de l'état n'est
pas adaptée et et je le dis à nos
collectionneurs
quand on se faisait le porte parole des
collectivités locales en disons que la
lodeom à oublier à oublier les
collectivités locales qui jouent un rôle
fondamental
pas simplement en tant que buvard
sociale mais aussi en matière de
développement économique dans la région
de la réunion investi un milieu d'un
milliard d'euros pour réaliser cette la
route des tamarins et qu'on peut
multiplier ces exemples
c'est à dire que ce sont des
investissements qui booste l'activité
économique qui dynamisent l'activité
économique
hors la loi qui a été proposé a été une
loi qui s'est focalisée exclusivement
sur la défiscalisation et n'ont pas
apporté une aide au profit des
collectivités locales qui jouent un rôle
fondamental n'est pas simplement en
guyane à la réunion en martinique
guadeloupe mais aussi en métropole nous
savons bien que les collectivités
locales jouent un rôle fondamental dans
la commande publique autour de 70 % en
métropole
et quand nous voyons les chiffres en
dans les dom c'est plus de 90%
donc il ya une nécessité de reconsidérer
ce déficit
structurelle des collectivités locales
ça veut dire que il faut reposer la
question de la solidarité de la
péréquation d'en discuter à tout à
l'heure en matière de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement et je veux
citer deux exemples pour bien montrer
que les collectivités locales centre
était d'une certaine façon et je pars
les collectivités d'outre-mer
là le critère notamment qui a été votée
l'autre jour il ya deux ans deux ou
trois ans de cela sur la dotation en
termes de superficie où il est préconisé
à peu près 5 euros par hectare c'est
bien sa part communes de montagne me
semble-t-il que la réunion fait partie
une partie montagneuse quand il s'agit
le projet que nous a démontré qu'il faut
faire dans l'eau passé de l'est vers
l'ouest
il s'agit bien d'aménager une zone
montagneuse emportant la réunion n'a pas
été retenu ne bénéficient pas de ces 5
euros alors que d'autres communes de la
métropole qui se situe en zone
montagneuse bénéficient de deux de ses
cinq euros nous nous sommes pas mon but
en colle comme les autres collectivités
locales au même niveau de la moyenne
nationale à savoir 3 euros avec une
double peine pour la guyane
parce que nous somme plafonnée non je
crois que l'intérêt de cette mission
c'est de bien faire comprendre à tous
nos collègues sénateurs qu' il y à une
réalité il ya une réalité qui est tout à
fait différente sa demande nécessité de
rattraper cela donc ça il s'agit
d'aborder la question de la solidarité
de revoir la question de la péréquation
maintenant par rapport aux finances des
collectivités locales effectivement pour
rattraper ce retard
indispensable pour vous chers collègues
mes chers amis libéraux n'ont d'abord
résidents moi je voudrais dire
que nous avons bien compris les réalités
de la réunion les difficultés qu'ils se
sont rencontrés
nous avons aussi moi je pense c'est mon
ressenti
après trois jours de mission beaucoup
d'espoir beaucoup d'espoir parce que
nous avons rencontré des gens des
personnes des professionnels d'une très
grande qualité
nous avons rencontré une capacité dans
ce territoire à imaginer à innover à
créer avec une très forte volonté
quelque chose d'extraordinaire je pense
que là vous avez vraiment pris à bras le
corps
moi je pense votre destin et mais je
vais un peu plus loin je vais un peu
plus loin parce que il ne faut pas non
plus tout attendre il y a des choses à
faire que vous pouvez réaliser aussi
vous même que nous réalisons dans nos
départements français parce que nous
n'avons aussi moi je suis dans un
département rural dans l'ouest de la
france nous avons aussi nous rencontrons
des difficultés emière vous avez le
touriste aussi or si je vous parle du
tourisme c'est que je suis j'étais je
suis président d'audi de france et quand
même l'année passée où depuis deux ans
nous avons apporté beaucoup d'argent sur
le tourisme en guyane il ya un rapport
qui est et fait d'ailleurs à ce niveau
là vous devez en êtes vous en avez été
destinataire et je dois dire que sur le
plan du tourisme
vous avez qu'elle vous avez un véritable
travail là à organiser le tourisme c'est
l'industrie mauges dit souvent j'ai
l'habitude de dire si l'industrie du
pauvre parce que elle coûte pas mais
c'est la plus importante industrie que
l'on peut développer ont jusqu'à présent
nous avons fait souvent un tourisme de
cueillette
c'est à dire nous attendions et
aujourd'hui il faut être beaucoup plus
volontaire il faut être beaucoup plus
créatif et émaux je pense que là vous
avez aussi à réfléchir à ça ensemble
il faut créer des nouveaux produits
touristiques sur la guyane parce qu'il
n'y a pas de doute que vous pourrez pas
faire compte
france à maurice à côté vous n'avez pas
les mêmes plages mais vous avez 35 km de
plat je crois me souvenir c'est ce que
j'avais donnera dans rapport d'audit
france vous avez par contre un tourisme
intérieur
moi qui suis un homme de haut du rural
moi je vous dis que le tourisme
intérieur et quand on s'adresse aux
européens et aux européens du nord en
particulier c'est pas de la plage qui
veulent s'y du tourisme intérieur c'est
voir ce qui se passe à l'intérieur vous
avez un volcan exploiter vous avez des
randonnées à mettre en place vous avez
un tourisme de patin vous avez un
patrimoine naturel extraordinaire
alors moi je peux dire après cette
mission
oui nous avons compris et moi j'ai en ce
qui me concerne j'ai bien compris mais
je dois dire que un certain nombre de
choses qu'on ne peut pas laisser dire
que la métropole n'a rien apporté
mo je crois que elle est là elle a
beaucoup apporté mais est aussi en
ensemble ensemble ils via un rattrapage
eh bien oui moi je pense que cette
mission va permette justement de faire
ressortir ce qui ce rattrapage
mais je pense aussi que ensemble nous
devons et et en particulier dans
certains domaines nous devons ensemble
réfléchir
peut-être sur des produits nouveaux
alors il faut que ce soit tous soient
d'accord ici pour les biens personnels
j'ai dit ici sont venus pendant trois
jours ici et on la présentait et
d'énormes succès de la réunion la
réunion bouge l'avenir se développe nous
avons vu la voix contre les gens qui ont
une volonté commune de développer le
département dont les gens qui se sont
qui s'en sont organisés en filière pour
pouvoir développer
on a vu que tout le monde rame est dans
le même sens tout le monde amis mais
chacun avec ses propres sa propre
sensibilité vos parents on ne dit pas
que la france n'a pas n'a pas investi
ici on dit pas que la france peut donc
nous sommes un territoire français il ne
lui faut pas et il faut le savoir en
permanence et c'est bon pour il faut
auxerre la face on fait parfois encore
penser au centre exécutif mais ce n'est
pas la chose comme un procès il y a des
cinq succès ici c'est indéniable hisquin
malhonnête intellectuellement ne pas le
reconnaître il y a une volonté de
développer quelle volonté de seulement
seulement on a aussi reçu cette onde
message disant que saute dans la
répartition des richesses
il y as parfois de laissés pour compte
il faut le dire aussi
et ça on l'a entendu il faut qu'on soit
un peu de tout sur tout mais madame la
présidente du conseil général
je ne veux vraiment pas être conseil
général je préside aujourd'hui ils
souffraient que prévu je vous passe la
parole parce que nous avons et puis
après le pascal broulis
merci monsieur le président d'avoir
voulais remercier les sénateurs et
l'ensemble de vos collègues sur 3 jours
vous êtes venu et je crois que vous avez
constaté que sur ce petit département
français jeune département en 60 ans les
investissements de l'europe comme les
investissements de l'état en porter ses
fruits
et je crois vraiment pouvoir dire que
même si nous rencontrons encore des
difficultés parce qu'il y a des retards
structurels et je ne parlerai dans un
moment des finances principalement des
finances qui concerne le conseil général
la collectivité que je préside
ces efforts ont porté ses fruits
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
une jeunesse formée
nous avons des structures qui ressemble
à n'importe quel autre département de
métropole mais nous continuons à garder
nos handicaps structurels et au fond
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé et quelle est
la situation depuis la 2eme
décentralisation la structure de notre
population qui reste encore jeune avec
des besoins en équipement encore
important avec la demande de
construction que ce soit sur les écoles
primaires ou bien les collèges ou encore
les lycées eh bien nous avons encore
investir et puis vous allez rappeler les
collectivités locales sont donneurs
d'ordre en termes de commandes publiques
et chaque année le conseil général de la
réunion nous apportons entre 250 à 270
millions d'euros d'investissement comme
nous apportons une aide à des communes
au travers le contrat de coopération
communale parce que il est vrai aussi
que les communes connaissent de part
justement une dgd qui n'est plus
suffisante aujourd'hui parce que la
population continue à augmenter parce
que nous avons des jeunes qui arrivent
sur le marché de l'emploi
alors oui le modèle de développement qui
a porté ses fruits et bien ce modèle là
s'essouffle et il nous appartient à nous
c'est pour ça que le président de la
république et je crois que c'est pour ça
que cette mission des sénateurs est ici
présents de rencontrer l'ensemble des
élus des forces vives pour se dire quels
autres modèles nous pouvons mettre en
place alors le conseil général de la
réunion
nous pouvons dire que les mécanismes
financiers liés à la deuxième
décentralisation ne nous permettent plus
aujourd'hui effectivement de compenser
ce que nous devons faire je parle
principalement je voulais d'hier la
compensation liée au rmi en 2004 les
départements en lui à gérer le rmi est
chez nous on sait que ça touche
énormément de personnes aujourd'hui
soixante sept mille allocataires du rmi
et la compensation ne correspond pas aux
dépenses que nous avons aujourd'hui a
effectué au sein du conseil général
de la même manière pour ce qui revient
aux personnes âgées l'allocation
personnalisée à l'autonomie
eh bien nous n'avons pas la compensation
nécessaire et bah ça creuse
les budgets comme pour les communes au
niveau du conseil général nous avons
aujourd'hui des budgets qui ne peuvent
plus répondre à ses besoins et nous
c'est la tei pp qui nous permet
effectivement de faire face à cela donc
il nous appartient effectivement de
montrer et de dire à l'ensemble des
sénateurs mais aussi à l'ensemble des
députés et aux membres du gouvernement
qu'il nous faut trouver autre chose qui
nous appartient à nous tous aussi dit
réfléchir pour que dans les années qui
viennent on puisse répondre à ces
demandes et comme nous sommes en période
de crise eh ben le le citoyen il se
retourne vers nous collectivités que ce
soit dans les communes où conseil
général en demandant à ce que nous
prenions en compte leur situation
spécifique
je pense aux jeunes en situation parfois
de rupture familiale ou de demandes
d'emploi je pense aux filles mères
je pense à tous les femmes âgées aux
personnes qui attendent un logement je
voudrais vous vraiment dire une chose je
voudrais que la lodeom et que vous même
vous soyez nos interprètes auprès de
tous ceux que vous allez rencontrer sur
sur deux demandes
la crise du logement dans les
départements d'outre-mer et
principalement à la réunion parce que
empêché les familles de s'abîmer sait
garder la cohésion sociale empêcher un
jeune de s'abîmer ses gardes et de la
cohésion sociale
et pourquoi est ce que les maires ou les
conseillers généraux et ben nous sommes
alarmés aujourd'hui c'est parce que nous
sentons bien que la demande devient plus
forte
la demande sociale devient plus forte et
quand nous qu on sera content parce que
66 % de notre budget sur 1 milliard 400
millions d'euros et donc il faut quand
même dire que l'europe et l'état
français nous donne des sous 1 milliard
400 millions d'euros c'est de l'argent
simplement la demande devient
grandissante et il nous faut trouver
peut-être je dirais un autre braqué
parce que la défiscalisation a aussi
apporté des effets pervers sur le prix
du foncier principalement à la réunion
et il nous appartient à nous de
réfléchir parce que les collectivités ne
pourront plus faire face à ses demandes
croissantes principalement en matière
sociale
nous il nous faudra attendre 2030 pour
que notre transition démographique soit
assurée et jusqu'à 2030 il nous faut
encore est accompagnée et une petite
suggestion
alors oui l'import le modèle l'import
substitution ça a porté ses fruits mais
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui il nous faut
réfléchir à comment importer avec les
pays de la zone environnant pourquoi est
ce que maurice ou l'afrique du sud peut
s'acheter des matériels avec les normes
anti cyclonique et payer moins cher
alors que nous nous sommes obligés
d'importer de l'europe ce qui fait que
tout ce qui arrive ici coûte plus cher
donc voilà des réflexions et il
appartient à nos députés à nos sénateurs
de porter un certain nombre de
réflexions au plus haut lieu parce que
nous savons qu effectivement la demande
sociale va grandissante
oui merci madame la présidente de choses
avant de passer la parole
à monsieur le maire après trois morts
vous mais vous dire que si nous sommes
ici c'est la décision du sénat que ce
soit clair et autre chose
vous prenez la victoire souci de parler
des finances locales vous avez parlé de
l'autre sociaux il ne peut avoir de
logements sociaux que si les communes
mettent à disposition des terrains mais
des terrains viabilisés et pour
collecter pour les coller commune puisse
mettre des terrains viabilisés
il faut qu'elle ait des financements
donc des fonds propres si et c'est un
problème des finances locales
et puis vous avez parlé le problème de
l'insertion de la ligne dans son
environnement géographique dans l'océan
indien est bien là nous avons des
problèmes des écueils avec l'europe
messaoud ça fera l'objet de discussions
plus tard monsieur le maire de port je
voulais intervenir à nouveau
disons pour bien attirer votre attention
sur le fait qu' on a des retards
importants
je pense qu effectivement depuis 50 ans
il ya eu des réalisations qui ont été
faites un est sûre ce tous les plans il
ya eu des avancées mais le fait est que
aujourd'hui on est à 50 de poissons de
la population en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté
ça c'est un un taux qui est officiel ça
a été annoncé par l'insee ya quelques
semaines de cela a été confirmé par
d'autres études qui ont été faites ici
de façon tout à fait officielle donc on
a une situation sociale catastrophique
et on est confronté à cette situation là
avec les retards sur le plan des
équipements on est encore à construire
des écoles maternelle l'école primaire
la première adjointe de la mairie tenu à
rappeler qu'il ya un certain nombre de
communes actuellement qui sont mises en
examen
parce que on est on a porté atteinte à
l'environnement
nos stations d'épuration ne l'étant pas
aux normes européennes
bon et ça représente des investissements
meurent pour deux communes qui se sont
regroupés en
un syndicat unique pour l'assainissement
on va bientôt démarrer une extension et
une mise aux normes de la station sénat
ça va nous coûter 25 millions d'euros
et on va devoir financer ça et c'est
pour nous une charge lourde qu'on aura à
financer donc on est confronté à cette
situation paradoxale avec des choses
qu'on peut considérer comme en pointe
mais en même temps on a une situation
sociale extrêmement difficile et c'est
ça qui fait la difficulté aujourd'hui
parce que les communes en particulier se
trouve face à cette situation là et il
ya des demandes d'emploi de formation de
logement et c'est des sujets sur
lesquels on n'a pas forcément la réponse
comprend le logement par exemple avec ce
qu'on a eu depuis quelques années on a
fait le constat d'une augmentation très
importante du prix du foncier faire du
logement social
aujourd'hui avec les coups de fond c'est
qu'on a c'est quasiment impossible donc
il faut que les collectivités
interviennent et depuis quelque temps
dans le montage des opérations de
logements sociaux
si la communauté d'agglomération
n'intervient pas haute de dix mille
euros par logement
eh bien ça ne se fait pas et on a les
difficultés parce que les coûts plafond
n'ont pas été revues depuis un certain
nombre d'années et les appels d'offres
infructueux
on n'arrive pas le poids 7 ans
d'opération à trouver des sociétés pour
faire de logement social donc on est
véritablement d'une situation
extrêmement difficile et il faut voir
les solutions on parle de de recettes
notamment de la fiscalité avec les
appelle les accords de partenariat
économiques qui vont se faire dans
quelques années
quid de de l'octroi de mer comment le
toit de mer face concilier avec la libre
circulation de marchandises à travers
des accords de partenariat économique
avec les pays de la zone donc l'attitude
qu'on est qu'on a aujourd'hui par
rapport à certaines recettes cette
inquiétude à moi je pense qu'elle est
fondée et il faut qu'on arrive à trouver
des solutions qui soient compatibles et
qui nous permettent d'avoir une recette
non seulement conforté mais également
augmenter si on veut faire face aux
problèmes aux urgences ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui et je pense que au niveau
des communes où on n'a pas la même
structure de recettes fiscales que les
communes de france avec l'octroi de mer
ici mais globalement je pense que les
recettes pour la réunion sont inférieurs
en moyenne ou recettes fiscales ou des
dotations de l'état les communes
françaises ont en moyenne donc là je
crois qu'il ya un effort à faire au
niveau du rattrapage et à faire en sorte
qu'on puisse bénéficier de dotations
exceptionnelles pour faire face à la
situation
autant et aussi les besoins nouveaux on
n'arrête pas de constater contenu de la
démocratie qui est particulièrement
qu'ici on est à 80 800 mille habitants
et les chiffres donnent un million
d'habitants dans moins de deux décennies
ce qui fait que là il y aura des besoins
nouveaux qui peuvent être quantifiés
année après année si on veut rattraper
le temps et surtout si on veut pouvoir
arriver à un niveau moyen national dans
les dix ou quinze ans à venir je crois
que ya une faune exceptionnelle qu'il
faut faire et les cours une doit pouvoir
bénéficier de dotations
lors des chefs mais il ya peut-être là
effectivement apposé de façon secours on
est sur ce plan là est bien le niveau de
fiscalité et de dotation en adéquation
avec cette situation
je retiendrai par une fiscalité on en
revient tout à l'heure j'ai pas ça parle
de suite à mon collègue sud où l'eau oui
je crois que pendant ces quelques jours
où nous avons parcouru votre île on a
l'habitude de dire quelqu'un de dire il
n'est de richesse que donne je crois que
la réunion elle est très riche en femme
et un homme de qualité actif dynamique
mais vous avez une situation économique
qui est social qui est particulièrement
difficile
moi je crois que on a beaucoup parlé de
l'état alors je ne veux pas faire de
politique politicienne ni être
désagréable mais les thaïs incarne ici
un carences dans un gouvernement est
dans une politique et je crois que
suivant la politique qui est menée par
notre gouvernement au niveau national
cela a des conséquences cela des
conséquences et une situation qui qui
fait des décisions qui font que la
situation de nos communes
métropolitaines est difficile que la
situation de nos populations à métropole
est difficile évidemment avec la la
situation que vous avez en outre mer
s'est accentuée et s'est multiplié à
puissance x
quand on fait une certaine politique la
matière le service public ça des
conséquences à métropole ça a des
conséquences beaucoup plus graves chez
vous à l'île de la réunion
quand on fait une certaine politique en
matière d'éducation ou suppriment des
postes nous annoncer qu'il y avait des
postes supprimés à l'université par
exemple de la réunion ça des
conséquences dont il ya quand même des
choix politiques qu'on ne peut occulter
on est pas on n'est pas là dans et
suivant les choix que l'on fait cela des
conséquences
demain dans l'action quotidienne alors
moi je crois que ce qu'il faut on a
beaucoup parlé de l'europe
on a beaucoup parlé de l'europe moi je
suis très investi au sénat dans les
affaires européennes
ce que je suis vice-président de la
commission des affaires européennes j'ai
été particulièrement choquée lorsque
nous avons visité la route des tamarins
une très belle réalisation du conseil
régional de la réunion de voir qu'il y
avait très peu de l'argent de l'état
française il y avait de l'argent de
l'europe 15 % nous ont dit c'est
pratiquement que de l'argent de l'europe
et 85% du conseil régional de la réunion
eh bien pourquoi parce qu'au niveau
européen il y a une idée qui est une
bonne idée qu'il faut remettre à niveau
les régions et les pays qui sont en
dessous de la moyenne de richesse de
ligne de l'union ça a été fait au niveau
européen stricto sensu s'est fait aussi
vous avez parlé de l'objectif m ça ne
peut évoluer maintenant mais c'est fait
aussi pour l'est pour les dom et je
pense qu'il faut qu'au niveau national
au niveau gouvernemental on fasse la
même chose il faut faire un effort
considérable sur les départements
d'outre-mer pour les remettre à niveau
par rapport à la métropole
ce que l'europe a fait pour certains
pays le sud de la grèce
le sud de l'italie l'irlande le sud de
l'espagne où ces zones maintenant ont
été remises à niveau eh bien il faut que
le gouvernement français ce que moi je
suis désolé l'état il s'incarne en une
politique et dans un gouvernement il
faut que le gouvernement français le
fasse maintenant pour les départements
d'outre-mer en général et pour la
réunion en particulière j'aurais
beaucoup de choses entre d'autres choses
à dire mais je ne souhaite pas être trop
longue mais je le répète l'état
s'incarne dans un gouvernement et dans
une certaine politique
merci il nous reste plus que 13 minutes
deux minutes donc je pense avoir la
banane borvo ensuite les 13000 qui
resteront soient consacrés sont
réservées à un anneau sera réservé à nos
collègues de la réunion
c'est pareil mais tout est un peu comme
ceux qui détaille tout après merci je
vais être très très bref je voulais
simplement dire que si nous sommes ici
des sénateurs d'autres maires et des
sénateurs hexagonaux dix ans c'est parce
que notre assemblée on a décidé à
l'unanimité des présidents de groupes
ainsi et donc c'est une mission
parlementaire
et si nous sommes ici c'est parce qu'il
ya les fortes revendications qui se sont
exprimés de façon diverse outre-mer dans
la période toute récente continue de
s'exprimer et que nous voulions va faire
notre travail de parlementaires n'ont
pas vous dire ce qu'il fallait faire
mais écoutez à ce qu'on parlement
évidemment il faut des majorités donc
écouter pour essayer de répondre avec
évidemment nos différences nos
différents analyse est bon les batailles
que nous pouvons mener chacun pour ce
que nous croyons sans doute au niveau du
parlement national auquel nous
appartenons tous
donc moi je vais m'en tenir à la
fiscalité je le dire deux choses
ici nous avons bien entendu ce qu'il en
était des difficultés à la fois la
vitalité comme tout le monde le dit cela
vit à juste titre mais des difficultés
propres qu'elles soient historiques
qu'elle soit géographique bon et c'est
vrai que du point de vue de la fiscalité
par exemple l'octroi de mer quand on est
dans un environnement où les pays
émergents vont bien entendu protéger la
production locale souvent avec des
salaires plus bas
il est clair que l'europe de se poser la
question par rapport à ses territoires
d'outre-mer et donc l'octroi de mer à
mon avis devrait être défendu fortement
par le gouvernement de la france au
niveau européen voyez pas ce que c'est
un intérêt je dirais pour tout le monde
quelque sorte et tout particulièrement
bien sûr pour vos productions nationales
ensuite sur le plan plus large la
fiscalité mais je crois qu'il ya un très
très gros problème de la fiscalité
locale parce que les collectivités
locales sont de plus en plus de charges
qui leur ont été transférées par l'état
sans compensation idoine et qui plus est
on voit bien qu'on est dans une période
où et quand même les riches les plus
riches ont eu beaucoup de dégrèvements
fiscaux dans la dernière période
et maintenant on parle de supprimer la
taxe professionnelle donc en quelque
sorte c'est qui va payer
la fiscalité est ce que celles et ceux
qui ont la chance en quelque sorte
d'être salarié d'un salarié disons
modestes moyens ou est ce que quand même
on va avoir des injustices fiscales qui
permettent d'une part d'avoir des
ressources fiscales importantes qui
repose et sur les plus riches
et aussi sur les entreprises qui font
des bénéfices pas celles qui n'en font
pas et puis est-ce qu'on va avoir une
véritable péréquation qui fait que les
collectivités locales qui sont les plus
sûrs les plus grandes difficultés des
difficultés c'est pas que des 10
culte et qui ont le plus de jeunes le
plus de vieux favre il ya des
spécificités des collectivités et vous
avez les vôtres qui leur permettent
d'avoir des ressources égales disons
pour l'égalité et pas des ressources
ridicule parce qu'elles n'ont pas la
chance d'avoir des très riches sur leur
territoire et des grandes entreprises
je remercie le verra jones et le oui
bonjour à tous on peut que se féliciter
bon d'avoir une mission de
parlementaires qui viennent dans notre
île regardez de plus près les
difficultés que nous rencontrons
bon je vais pas réinventer tout ce qui
s'est dit simplement remettre l'accent
sur les difficultés de nos finances
locales dans la mesure où ça a été dit
par les uns et les autres est donc mais
seulement recettes recentrer le
par rapport à ce que nous rencontrons
dans notre commune 75 % de notre budget
thème path dans le fonctionnement on a
pallié dans l'histoire ça a été dit par
le président tout à l'heure une
situation de l'emploi difficile dans
notre île et donc on a fait office de
tampon visage par rapport à ces
difficultés là ce qui a entraîné
effectivement ces dérives budgétaires
qu'il nous faut aujourd'hui corrigé
doucement mais encore faut-il que on ait
les moyens de faire ça aujourd'hui on
les attend pour reconnaître qu'il année
ensuite on a des besoins énormes en
investissements structurants dans notre
dans nos collectivités dans nos communes
il en a effectivement d'énormes
difficultés pour mettre ça pour mettre
ça en place vis-à-vis de 10 avec
difficulté que nous rencontrons
l'économique nous avons donc sur notre
parle de votre commune de ma commune
principalement c'est une communauté
relativement peu développées conomique
mans qui veut se tourner vers le
tourisme
puisqu'on est relativement bien placé
dans ce siècle pour ce secteur là encore
faut-il qu'on met en place tous les
toute la structuration fond et c'est pas
facile vous devez vous en douter
voilà un peu la difficulté que nous
rencontrons une grosse partie les trois
quarts de notre budget c'est du budget
de fonctionnement on est on a des
recettes fiscales relativement difficile
chez nous par rapport aux taxes
d'habitation taxe sur le bâti taxe aux
siens qui sont relativement différente
par rapport à la métropole donc on a des
recettes fiscales
déséquilibrée entre guillemets par
rapport à ce que vous pouvez rencontrer
en métropole et on a cet octroi de mer
qui nous qui nous permet effectivement
d'avoir deux d'équilibrer ses budgets
aujourd'hui on est très très inquiet sur
l'avenir d'une manière d'une haute même
si c'est pas 2014 l'échéance de l'octroi
de mer on se fait pas beaucoup
d'illusions sur le long terme
donc il faut absolument qu'on
réfléchisse très
heureusement à une pérennisation de nos
de nos recettes fiscales avec la taxe
foncière la taxe professionnelle qui qui
va disparaître à terme ou tout le moins
bien limiter on va se retrouver pieds
poings liés avec des dotations de l'état
en sachant pertinemment que les
dotations de l'état sont calculés un
jour sur une base mais l'évolution est
très compliqué à faire suivre et donc on
ne peut qu'être inquiet sur sur cet
avenir là léger manteau rien tout le
monde l'a dit retrouve à table
oui monsieur le maire les seuls combats
perdus d'avancé
c'est ce que ne livre pas donc vigilance
ou le poids de mer et battons-nous
monsieur jean paul bigard tous les vins
du président moi je vais vous dire que
je suis confiant confiant pas d'un
optimisme béat mais d'une confiance
raisonnée tête et d'inquiétude à cause
de la crise qui sévit fpt et qui ont été
entraînés par une faillite du système
financier mondial dont personne ne
mesure ni la durée ni les conséquences
mais hormis cette inquiétude je pense
qu'il faut être confiant et relativiser
les choses par rapport à plusieurs
facteurs d'abord relativiser par rapport
à notre histoire quand on regarde ce
qu'était cette île comme l'a dit si bien
mon ami eric doligé et qu'on voit
aujourd'hui on est la réunion les autres
dom y compris il ya un chemin parcouru
que tout cet océan de misère qui nous
entourent aurait bien aimé parcourir
ici on est soigné mieux que dans
certains pays d'europe
mieux ici y'a l'échec scolaire mis à
l'échec scolaire aussi dans d'autres
départements français mais on est
département depuis 50 ans seulement et
je suis d'accord que ma collègue premier
adjoint au maire annie que ça c'était en
fait il faut l'éradiquer mais ça ne se
fait pas en un jour parce que c'est un
problème d'environnement social c'est un
problème d'accompagnement scolaire c'est
moins de moyens ça promet mais on avance
on avance on avait cinquante bastille et
en 1955
on en a plus de trois ou quatre mille
aujourd'hui sont des progrès relativiser
et aussi prendre conscience que la
responsabilité partagée
il n'ya pas l'état d'un côté quelle que
soit la majorité moi j'ai voté la
confiance au gouvernement car on peut
pas me soupçonner d'être complètement
fermé oui je sais pas j'ai pas voté la
censure en 1908 vérifiez vous verrez
parce que la csg a été une bonne réforme
et quand je vais demander sur la
supprimerait on m'a dit non parce
qu'elles savent la silhouette et lui dit
monsieur ne supprime pas que vous avez
au pouvoir il vaut mieux que j'avais
tout de suite donc relativiser pourquoi
parce que aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
un climat de crise il faut que nous
soyons responsables responsable parce
que la solide à nous vivons de trois
moyens
la solidarité européenne la solidarité
nationale est ce que j'appelle la
solidarité interne c'est la production
de richesses qui produit une fiscalité
et la solidarité interne conjuguée à la
nationale à l'européenne permet aux dom
d'avancé dans les années à venir il
faudra être responsable d'abord en
sachant que la solidarité européenne
n'augmentera plus elle va même diminué
parce qu'il ya des pays d'europe qui ont
un niveau de vie plus faible que le nom
la solidarité nationale aussi et par
conséquent il va falloir se retrousser
les manches pour produire plus de
richesse dans les domaines qui ont été
prévus dans la lodeom et c'est pour ça
qu'on veut pas dire qu'on est au sénat
dans une logique de parlotte mais dans
une logique d'action
je signale quand même quand le moment
nous sommes rentrés tous collèges
confondus dans l'hémicycle du sénat
le déficit de la france est terre 104
milliards et lorsqu'on a eu voté la
lodeom ce même déficit s'était passé à
105 milliards simplet lodeom a coûté un
milliard au contribuable français aux
générations futures
ça c'est pas de la parole c'est de
l'action dans des domaines clés que sont
les tlc l'agroalimentaire l'énergie
renouvelable et tout ça en valorisant ça
nous allons augmenter la solidarité
interne et donc la fiscalité locale et
quand tu devras l'octroi de mer j'étais
en mission à l'époque remis par monsieur
raffarin pour faire le rapport sur le
bras de mer qui a donné ce sursis de dix
ans je pense qu'une bonne fois pour
toute et j'ai dit à mes collègues de la
guyane
j'ai dit au président larcher il va
falloir qu'on se réunisse
ce dossier et extraire du 299 2 du
traité d'amsterdam toutes ses capacités
à savoir une directive communautaire qui
règlent ce problème au fond on peut pas
avoir l'épée de damoclès sur l'une des
principales ressources des communes et
faire voter l'amendement mon cher
collègue larcher sur une prise en compte
des handicaps des contraintes comme un
dictateur mon collègue de la guyane des
contraintes qui pèsent sur l'ailé les
finances locales
de telle sorte qu'on puisse aussi voir
l'horizon dégagé pour les années à venir
et bien travaillé pour ces dom qui sont
une richesse pour la france pour les
raisons qui ont été vos qu'à savoir
notre puissance maritime à savoir des
atouts considérables pour leur fille
merci mon cher collègue roland gélita
reste un peu moins de cinq minutes oui
je vais rectifier il ya tellement
d'inquiétudes avec cette menace sur
l'octroi de mer j'ai fait un dépassement
de langage pour l'octroi de mer
c'est vrai c'est une menace elle n'est
pas encore reçu primé mais bon alors moi
quand on parle à chaque fois de
développement de la réunion les
problèmes et tout on parle de rattrapage
je vais savoir rattrapage par rapport à
quoi rattrapage par rapport à qui sinon
rattrapage par rapport à nous mêmes par
rapport à nos enfants qui grandissent
par rapport à la démographie par rapport
à toute cette jeunesse qui arrivent sur
le marché de l'emploi ces actes
bacheliers 80% à 90% maintenant
bacheliers pour faire quoi
on ne sait pas on sait que chez nous
nous avons sans une centaine de docteur
inscrits à l'anpe il y en a qui vivent
avec le rmi
enfin bref donc ça et puis à chaque fois
qu'on présente non dits nos problèmes
que nous rencontrons est énorme problème
eh bien on est toujours sans se sentir
un peu obligé je ne sais pas de comparer
alors arrêtons un peu de comparer voilà
nous posons nos problèmes tout en
reconnaissant nos atouts et les avancées
qui ont eu dans notre pays depuis une
soixantaine d'années
enfin bref alors tout à l'heure mon
collègue a parlé de touristes mais bien
sûr il ya le développement du tourisme
on est en train en étendant bonne voie
je vais dire mais le problème on reste
toujours à tourner vers un touriste
européen
alors pourquoi est on a vu avec
l'épidémie de chikungunya comment notre
tourisme tomber mais ras le sol
au point où des hôteliers ont fermé aux
poids des hôtels au poids ou des
restaurants fermés sarkozy en corse a
donné un nombre phénoménal de chômeurs
pour tout simplement parce que nous
n'avons pas de visa il ya un problème
pour nos touristes étrangers juste à
côté des sud africains et d'autres qui
s'en fichent des moustiques parce qu'ils
ont l'habitude de vivre en reste avec
des maladies émergentes
il pouvait venir chez nous ils n'ont pas
pu nous ne pouvons pas régler ce
problème de visa ben voilà nous avons
bel et bien sûr une jeunesse formée mais
je viens de dire cette jeunesse formée
elle est au chômage pour la plus grande
partie nous savons 50% de notre jeunesse
est au chômage
nous avons beaucoup de projets certes
mais en même temps le paradoxe est que
nous avons 52 % de notre population qui
vivent en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
et ça nous ne savons pas encore comment
nous sortir de là et nous avons vu les
événements récents
justement a provoqué cette mission
parlementaire et là notamment sur les
baisses des prix du pouvoir dans le
pouvoir d'achat et nous disons il faut
casser les monopoles c'est vrai il
faudrait également bénéficier à ses
vrais peut-être mais dans quel
pourcentage mais surtout il faut se
tourner une bonne fois pour toute et
nous inscrire dans notre environnement
géographique nous donner la possibilité
nous délai donné une délégation de
compétences pour pouvoir signer pour
pouvoir commercer avec nos pays voisins
voilà aussi nos atouts et puis un autre
atout enfin il ya eu très récemment fait
un pas de deux ans un séminaire de
toutes les rup ici à la région
concernant la pêche et on nous a dit à
la réunion mais tout de suite maintenant
vous avez la possibilité de créer
quinze mille emplois pauvres jeunes
formés au jeune adam est aussi créé une
compagnie maritime pour commercialiser
sa mais tout ceci ce sont des paroles
des atouts mais ça ne se fait pas il
sait leur ou jeudi l'état ne nous
accompagne pas c'est là je dire l'état
ne nous accompagnera on ne le sent pas
dans pour nous permettre on parlait de
donner la canne à pêche
on est ici d'aider des crédits toujours
les crédits en contrat aidé deux mille
personnes vont être licenciées là et on
ne sait pas comment faire
ils vont être licenciés là et c'est le
recteur qui nous le disait encore hier
voilà et que si on nous donnait
justement ces outils pour nous permettre
de créer la richesse et une richesse
marchande
je pense que c'est là nos vrais soucis
quel que soit le gouvernement
ces gouvernements successifs ne nous ont
pas entendus
merci il laisse deux minutes je me suis
réduite et une 8 e niveau vote au second
tour mais messi comme celle a
pratiquement la conclusion je voudrais
dire à la mission quand elle partira
ayez en tête
une réunion qui bouge qui gagne qui est
investi et qui croient en elle même qui
croient en la france et trois ans
l'europe
ensuite depuis 81 partait aussi avec ce
qui va ce que depuis 81 l'état a
manifesté sa solidarité sur le plan
économique loi paul perben peu importe
le lors d'un père ben pons girardin
aujourd'hui la lodeom
si parce que les élus de tous bords ont
suffisamment convaincu l'état le
gouvernement présents de l'époque que
ces investissements ont pu être menées
et aux qu'aujourd'hui quand vous venez
la réunion le 29 avril 2009 ouvrant des
comptes effectivement qui a beaucoup de
dévolution et que nous sommes fiers
d'être debout et de regarder encore plus
loin enfin je terminerais monsieur le
président en faisant une proposition
pour vous dire que dans notre recherche
en matière d aide financière aux
collectivités
quelques collègues ce plan national nous
nous réfléchissons nous travaillons sur
sorte de prêt à taux zéro en matière
d'investissements sur une période donnée
pour les communes de façon que comme ça
ça laissera la dette ils n'auront plus
de remboursements d'emprunts si mesure
de ce style pouvait être mené
ça aiderait encore davantage à nos
communes collectivités d'investir très
bien je vous remercie monsieur le député
je remercie messieurs les sénateurs mais
chez les dames et messieurs les maires
madame la présidente
nous sommes venus se monte à ces 3 jours
3 jours de travail jour excusons auprès
de ceux que nous avons rencontrés pour
lesquels n'auront pu pas pu consacrer
suffisamment de temps pour les écouter
mais nous avons quand même rencontré une
réunion qui je crois a confiance en son
avenir qui est prête à relever les défis
les enjeux de notre époque mais aussi
nous avons rencontré une réunion qui a
aussi des inquiétudes et qui si elle à
coeur de mettre sur pied un contrat
social
par contre votre capot dans son économie
il faudrait que ce volet économique soit
aussi accompagné de contrat social deux
façons que tous trouvent les fruits du
développement suivant ce son travail et
suivant ce qu'ils méritent
je sens faite par conséquent nous cela
tombe à penser qu'en bonne chance à la
réunion vous pouvez toujours nous
adresser vos suggestions sur le site du
sénat
je vous remercie nous continuons de
travail êtes-vous toujours prêt à
recevoir vos propositions firme a mis
aux voix
et merci à tous pour la richesse de vos
échanges cette table-ronde à
l'initiative de la mission d'information
sur la situation des dom est terminé
merci de votre attention